[Music]
the people I look up to always say I'm
wrong so I've never looked for
affirmation from anybody I don't need a
cosign
I need a cosign from you got your
perspective don't you want to be happy
[Music]
you 25 years ago how to get lucky as
[ __ ] that's seven different people
thought you were good enough
signed distributed get on TRL [ __ ]
there's all these gatekeepers and then
you'd have to pray like hell that the
right song was picked not even by you
and your team by some [ __ ] executive
it's tone-deaf to the reality and then
if that song didn't pop your career was
over now you make good [ __ ] music you
put on SoundCloud Spotify YouTube and
Instagram and the [ __ ] market decides
it's the greatest era to be a musician
of all time the downside is you put out
[ __ ] and people [ __ ] [ __ ] on you and
people have soft feelings and are
insecure and don't want to be called
stupid corny ugly not good and they give
up because they value other people's
opinions over their own ambition and
that's why all my [ __ ] on Instagram if
you look real carefully under the facade
of my energy or whatever the [ __ ] I'm
saying I'm just trying to get people to
build their own self-esteem doesn't
matter what X Excel or worldstar or
5,000 comments or the 17 biggest names
in the game say it's been my biggest
banish my whole career nobody I've been
very innovative like in what I've done
like early to internet early the social
early like so everybody says I'm wrong
all the time the people I look up to
always say I'm wrong so I've never
looked for affirmation from anybody I
don't need a cosign
I need a cosign from the people that are
consuming my [ __ ] it feels nice when
Drake puts your music in his Instagram
story it doesn't hurt but it's the end
consumer
why have you continued to grind even
though you went out five years ago and
you're starting to have a real moment
now like why cuz you had no other
alternative like what was in your head
personally where I put all my mm-hmm we
didn't feel done yeah a lot of why cuz
you taste blood in the water just not
even that it's just like a lot of these
projects like you said the industry get
a hold of it you don't have your opinion
on it they picking the songs they don't
you know yeah I just feel like over the
years I was letting them do it cuz I
never been sad before so I was like
maybe they know what they talking about
respect that it's Lady Gaga at this lake
one of these mariah carey yeah you see
all the gold records when you walk in
all right show me even though I was
already on the up-and-up
I think my mistake was like hand in my
career over completely to these people
and then trust me because like you said
it's a hit or miss they might think they
know what they talking about but if it
don't work then it's like what it makes
artists day you know so there's a
percent Oh buddy here that has been like
watching when they hit it was there
they're doing when you miss it's your
fault I know that's why I started being
like let me get involved because y'all
doing stuff and I did it looked wrong
but when it is wrong they gonna say it's
me like you just said so now I'm kind of
like real hands-on with my project and I
really want to do it my way and put my
all into it and and if it hit the ground
in his eye he died on your [ __ ]
school it was he no offense I gave it to
everybody else you know accountability
good for you
[Music]
it is it is deeply my opinion that if
that the amount that far too many people
in her 20s and 30s maximize their down
payment on a home right leaving them
with no liquid to be able to do things
with them and if they are like me like I
said I write and are entrepreneurial and
on the offense that there are better
uses of their dollars than buying a home
because in renting a home or an
apartment they would take that to hit
you know you know theoretically that to
three hundred thousand that they're
putting down on a downpayment and
they're putting it to work whether in
their business building their brand
through their ads or investing in the
stock market I'm a prime example real
quick so I decided after I sold my last
house to rent and invest in a beverage
company and crushing it right now but
what is that that's my personal opinion
my business opinion is that if it's done
the right way homeownership will always
be a great investment
yes but the but but this is not a debate
if it's a great investment it's a debate
of instead of looking backwards of how
it's been over the last 70 years taking
into account what what the 20 year olds
of America are thinking today so if
you're Sally in rural Iowa and you're
putting down twenty thousand right on a
hundred thousand dollar home and you've
got my psychology I'm fascinated
based on them back to your point it
doesn't have to be that big of a
downpayment when the down payments are
smaller the multipliers are smaller too
so her hundred thousand dollar home ten
years later I'm fascinated by what
happens if she pays rent instead and has
that sixteen thousand to go to work
that's all hey guys thank you so much
for watching my video on YouTube I
wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a ridiculously
important project for me and I have a
funny feeling you can help if you drink
wine at all or know anybody that drinks
wine at all please go to empathy wines
calm right now and sign up for a
subscription whether it's a three pack
whether it's a six pack or whether it's
a whole case of each for the year
if you drink thirty
bottles of wine a year or give away 36
bottles of wine a year please sign up
for club empathy this project means the
world to me I could really use your
support
[Music]